thì sẽ dùng chíu của lưng xích tưởng trong ống dây khi ta dùng quyết năng nắm bàn tay
phải, bổ lưng đẹp
ah bây giờ, đầu tiên có nhà bây giờ sẽ dùng chíu rặng nghiệm chí trong ống dậy
chíu, của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu
quyết năng nắm bàn tay phải
nhớ trái người dùng có đăng nắm bàn tay
ở xa liệt, chíu của lưng xích tưởng
nắm bàn tay phải
chíu từ cô, tay nền ngón tay người nền hà chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu trong ống dậy
bây giờ, chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu
chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu, chíu của rặng nghiệm chíu
cho nó chíu của rặng 🎵
chíu
và hãy ngon chất này nó không nằm trên đường xử.
Tại vì ngon chất nó là một vật dụ.
Lần ra, để xác để tự cho
và xác để chíu của đường xử tử.
Hãy đầy và không đúng.
Để đầy và không đúng.
Để đỏ phải xưa ra thì hãy đầy cú không đúng.
Hãy đầy và không đúng.